said well millions of americans found
themselves out of work during the
pandemic
and now new opportunities are rising
just about every day due to companies
adapting to the guidelines
and allowing professionals now to
re-enter the workforce kirsten joyce
joining us now with some pretty timely
insights and some tips from a career
expert kirsten denise we wanted to pass
along the following key successful
strategies for people to build their
resume
if they had a career pause or lost their
job so here are some ideas take a class
or webinar to learn an in-demand skill
linkedin publishes the most in demand
heart and soft skills for the year about
what employers want but are difficult to
find skills like
blockchain cloud computing and
analytical reasoning
round out the top three for 2020.
volunteer
there are hundreds of professional
associations for every career field
imaginable
and that's a solid place to network give
yourself that sense of confidence so
when you do go in for that interview
you have something extra to talk about
and most importantly
certified career counselor for the
university of phoenix alex rush says
take stock of yourself i highly
recommend
you've been out of work for a while to
take some
career assessment tests so that you
understand the value
you bring to your employers understand
your brand
and understand how what you've done in
the past
translates into new careers that are of
high growth or those that align with
your values
skills interests and personality style
you can go to ncda.org that is the
national career development association
there are free resources and plenty of
assessments there
you can also find a certified career
counselor through ncda
to do a more deep dive into what your
value is in the workplace given the
current trends
tomorrow we'll explore all the useful
skills that stay-at-home moms and dads
half how they can
transfer them into the workforce so
that'll be tomorrow and of course we are
always compiling a list of job hiring
right here in the valley
you can find that list with links to
apply on our website 8newsnow.com